this is a production of cornell
university
um so
to all of our participants
welcome to
uh the inaugural
uh
simmon
pimp 411 seminar series we are so
thrilled that you're here
um there are so many people that have
come together to
um make this a reality um
and i i for one am absolutely jazzed to
see
y'all here and your interest in him
um so my name is zachary stansel i am
the usda hemp germplasm curator
so i want to very briefly
tell you a little bit about our work
and why we wanted to host hemp
411
so you know i'm curious how many of
y'all have heard of the idea of a seed
library
so a seed library is in many ways kind
of like a a regular library but instead
of books we hold these collections of
different kinds of scenes
so our work here in geneva new york is
to establish a collection of many
different diverse varieties of him
so our work is going to be collecting
growing out collect collecting new seeds
and distributing
these hemp varieties to many different
um
people all over the world
um so kind of like a regular library
those seeds can be checked out you don't
have to return them
by plant scientists
plant breeders educators and
many other groups of people
um so we hope that these efforts will
not only help protect the genetic
diversity of hemp
but allow universities companies farmers
and ultimately everyone to benefit from
the almost uncountably
uh diverse uses of hemp
so that's kind of you know the nuts and
bolts scientific element of our work but
you know in in the course of many
conversations um
we we are we realized that we're very
passionate about making hemp science be
a much more welcoming inclusive and and
diverse space
um especially to new scientists i i'm
hoping that some of the people
in this call have a future in hemp
science research or entrepreneurship
and we want to provide you information
and resources that can enable you to to
follow those dreams
um
so
very quickly i want to thank our
especially thank uh our everyone's
welcome here but we really want to thank
folks from alabama a m alcorn
central state del state florida a m fort
valley kentucky state langston u
lincoln u north carolina ant state
prairie view a m south carolina state
i'm from south carolina shout out
um
southern university tennessee state
tuskegee university of arkansas pine
bluff university of maryland eastern
shore virginia state and last but not
least virginia state university
real quick i want to thank tony barako
and george stack for really doing a ton
of the logistics work and and inviting
so many awesome speakers to this series
as well as
gemma autumn
um
autumn kennedy aaron rodgers
um so let's get down to what we're all
here for today i'm so excited to
introduce
um all y'all to jeff
koscheck
so jeff is the director at him genetics
international um he's been
passionate about him since 1998
he he's a seed grower
he studied agriculture at the university
of manitoba
um in 2012 he got a bachelor's degree at
athabasca university
um he was previously the director of the
canadian hemp trade alliance
and he currently holds a position of the
chair of the national variety trials
committee and minor use regulations
so once again welcome i present you jeff
actually i think tony wants to say a
little bit about question and answers
and the overall format so i'm going to
sign off
yeah
as jeff gets his screen ready um i just
wanted to mention that if you guys have
any questions throughout the lecture
please put them in the q a section
tab do not put them in the chat tab so
everything in the q a section
if we can get through it all uh i'll
hopefully be read during the q a
um
so yeah don't leave your questions till
the end
all right
take it away jeff
all right good to go well i'm assuming
uh you'll tell me if you can't see my
screen tony or somebody but it sounds
like uh yeah we hear me okay and the
screen's good
all good all right we'll fire away so
thank you very much uh zach for the
introduction i'll get a little bit into
my background on how i got involved with
camp um in in during the presentation
also but
what i'd like to do i guess is kind of
this it's uh you know really
realistically i guess it's a bit of a
dated present presentation already um
as zachary said i've been involved with
the hemp industry
mostly i would say as an applied
research agronomist to start with with
the province of manitoba so that's kind
of where i got my background in and how
i got started in hemp and became known
as the hemp guy uh contact for manitoba
and then
in 2015 uh switched over to industry and
and got involved with hemp genetics
international
so we'll go through a few things i'll
try to explain now
um what we're going to be
looking at
there we go
okay so basically it really doesn't
matter if we're talking about growing
hemp for cannabinoid extraction for
fiber or for grain production um how do
we grow hemp successfully so some of
these things are are applicable to all
three of those uh economic returns for
for hemp um but some of the things that
you need to ask yourself uh whether
you're a producer or a processor so uh
obviously what is the market demanding
and what you want to do is is be able to
you you need to be able to
identify what that market is demanding
how can you supply especially as a
farmer and us as agronomists and
researchers how can we assist farmers to
supply a high quality hemp
and what i suggest is it's a systematic
approach required to maximize quality so
it's like any other commodity or crop
that we grow so proper planning is is a
necessity
obviously we're all here together on the
webinar and that's uh a part of it
agronomics as i said as a as a
recovering applied research agronomist
that's dear to my heart
and
it's it's a crop that will will confuse
you sometimes so there's different
harvest and storage practices that you
have to be aware of uh you know really
with regards to all again all three
aspects of grain fiber in canada
so we look at agronomy you know we all
know that we need to take a look at
field selection crop rotation variety
selection
seeding um everything was eating
fertility weed control harvest
um and so getting right into so field
selection so
zachary and i were discussing a little
bit uh just earlier said you know what
was it like
you know getting involved with hemp in
canada in 1998
and i said it's probably not much
different than in the u.s where where i
think this is going on to a certain
degree where we we had interested
growers but they would never kind of
have their field sort of in their best
fields the field would be kind of in the
back quarter the back 40 you know kind
of maybe not the best soil
so we had a ton of catastrophes because
of that um nobody really wanted to sort
of be the the coffee shop talk as far as
that person's growing hemp you know
they're this and that so you know we've
come miles and miles from that where now
when we talk to growers it's more about
the stuff that we're going to talk about
today so crop rotation history
um herbicide history is is is extremely
important and that falls in place
of course with crop rotation um but with
herbicide history that hemp is quite
susceptible to most herbicides and is
quite uh um
it yeah a lot of the residual herbicides
uh can cause a problem with
establishment and establishment is one
of the toughest things to get your head
wrapped around with him
fertility levels um i know first
starting out
you know you go to the university of
google and everybody's saying well this
crop can grow without any
any nutrients whatsoever you don't have
to take care of it you just put it on
the ground and it's going to grow and
and and you know save the world
essentially which uh which it can but
it's a tall plant it's an aggressive
plant which means that it needs its
nutrients so it is not a nitrogen fixer
as also i've seen occasionally it's a
high user of nitrogen a high user of
potassium
so we have to make sure that we can feed
that crop accordingly because it is a
crop now it's not just something that's
uh grown for the fun of it
weeds what kind of are what are problem
leads with hemp it's the same thing
hemp does not necessarily have a strong
or even an ileopathic effect on other
wheats it relies on its plant structure
the the biomass to shade out weeds and
rob it rob weeds of the nutrients so
the advantage comes when you can get
ahead when the plant can get ahead of
weeds but there can certainly be issues
where where you know if the wheat
competition is either head to head or
weeds have a head start hemp will have a
very difficult time getting through
problem leads so
again that's another sort of myth that
we need to make sure that people are
aware of
and trash management and i shouldn't
actually have trash management there's
two things here i guess that you know it
can be considered you know that one
man's trash is another magic treasure so
the fiber industry how do we you know
the grain industry is what was really
moving the industry and forward in
canada for a number of years over the
last five years we're moving more into
um again turning that laminate to
lemonade so that fiber obviously has an
extremely high value and if you're not
if you do not have an area where
you can get rid of your fiber in an
economic fashion or or a way to to turn
it into
some cash for you uh it can be a real
issue as far as what crops come in next
year so
i shouldn't say trash management i
should just say residue management
so what kind of soil properties are we
looking for so again we want uh
basically uh you know kind of your best
soil it's a moderate soil texture uh
loam or or clay loam
saniloam it's not to say that hemp
couldn't do well on heavy clays but it
really just does not like its feet wet
and so that is the issue and and
compaction uh essentially actually any
skinny soil ever irregularity sorry
in uh in your field you know if you
think you've got a perfectly good field
that's uh from corn in the corner uh not
going to cause you any problems then
then hemp will be the one crop that will
show you where your problems are so
sandy soils are good because they
actually uh you know you don't have the
issue of sand standing water but it does
need moisture
uh needs upwards of 12 to 15 inches of
moisture you know to reach its you know
genetic potential for yields so
non-saline good tilth you know in other
words some of your best land you'd want
to be planting hemp on
this is what happens when we don't have
that
internal drainage or or if we get a
significant rain effect which seems to
be just about every second reign of
event is a significant one so this was a
uh
a section of hemp uh for seed production
and you can see where
the you know he was able to seed right
across everything we had a significant
rain event come
uh when the crop was probably about uh
you know probably about two weeks after
and you could definitely see anywhere
where the water was ponding for a little
while or sitting uh hemp did not take
that very well we've got weeds growing
in there
this area right in the bottom right hand
corner that's the compaction issue
that's where the trucks come into the
field so
um so yeah if if there's anywhere in the
field that you think uh has a soil type
issue then hemp's going to give you um
an indicator of that
so variety selection and this is uh this
is becoming more and more important
we've got a number of uh breeding
companies uh in the u.s now uh
developing hemp varieties um
we as hemp genetics have been in the
business since about 2005 2006
with varieties but you can see just from
this photo alone this again is from my
the good old days as they say so we've
got a difference in height here we've
got some uh male flowers in this variety
you can see the white
um we've got some monacious varieties
these are dioecious uh you know what
yields better there's a dioecius yield
better than ammonitis and why is there a
bonyisha so we'll we'll kind of tap into
that a little bit here so when we're
looking at uh variety selection and this
is where uh you know i was just kind of
looking at all the
shoutouts and the hellos
we've got a lot of researchers a lot of
uh research institutes hemp research
data is somewhat scarce and and this is
you know again dear to my heart as an
agronomist as a seed sales person i need
to get that a good handle on what
research is out there and it has to be
in my mind it has to be replicated data
that's analyzed
localized data
obviously the more site years the better
it's just all the things that we know
that are are important for making those
decisions the coefficient of variation
etc all of those things need to be
addressed
but some of the things i guess just from
an agronomic standpoint are obviously
yield if we're talking about grain
fiber or cannabinoid cbd yield is uh is
the king right um
when it comes into
uh both again fiber and grain height is
very important we want more biomass for
the fiber crops we want less biomass
more seed head for um for the grain
varieties that you can still easily
harvest disease susceptibility there are
certain uh cultivars that uh are more
susceptible than others to the likes of
botrytis or
[Music]
scleretinia
a number of different things herbicide
tolerance
i also
chair the minor use committee for the
chta and work with the ir4
program in the u.s and there are
differences in herbicide tolerance and
i'll just name one as a as a
one that we have uh used for in canada
is called bromoxinal so not gromox but
bromoxanal or bucktroll
so you know a lot of
all of the hdi varieties have a
extremely high tolerance of bremock snow
but there's some cultivars out there
that if you
uh drove by even with the herbicide in
the backyard truck you're going to see
some leaf browning and potentially some
some issues
many times you get that in with hemp's
aggressive growth nature it'll grow
through that but there are differences
maturity so a lot of the varieties are
are photoperiod sensitive so it's not as
uh
it's not as
a big a deal if you're at the same
latitude but there certainly are
differences between some varieties um
shelling is a is a big one again on the
grain side of things
i'll show some pictures shortly but as
hemp matures and dries down the brac
material that's surrounding protecting
the seed basically opens up and that
seed is exposed so whether it's birds
and again birds is a huge one and i'm
not sure if i've got birds on here but
shelling is is associated also with
birds and if you're doing any sort of
research make sure that you have a bird
control measure in place of some sort uh
it's one thing to have a quarter section
160 acre field and have a few blackbirds
circling it but you get a flock of
blackbirds in a in a research plot and
they'll do you some damage in a very
short period of time
there was one question already about
cannabis cannabinoid content and i'll
put thc in that um so there is a
variance between
whoops
there is a variance between varieties
there too and and seed size on the grain
side of things it's quite important too
because
as a farmer uh a smaller seed size ends
up your
uh your screenings you know who's you
know that seed that when the seed
cleaner takes it uh to get it ready for
to clean it for a processor uh you could
be losing a lot of seed just due to
seedy size so a large seed size but then
what's the composition
and we'll get into that as far as the
size of the hall in hearts and and how
we can utilize that so there's lots to
lots to talk about there lots to know um
and we've kind of gone through that
so i mentioned uh the photo tropic
plants uh i think for most of us we kind
of understand that so as the days get
shorter the plant detects that um so it
starts to go into its uh
it's a reproductive cycles i guess or or
puts some of that energy into
reproduction as opposed to just biomass
growth and the issue that we have here
is when we're moving some of the
genetics from canada uh further in
latitude uh certainly that
planet you know can't detect the
sunlight difference like say if we moved
one of our varieties into texas or
florida
there just isn't enough of a difference
in day length early in the season that
the plant is tricked into thinking that
it already has to start setting seeds so
we end up getting flowering happening
way too early and stuff so
so that's it has to be noted and uh
and there's genetics and there's ways
that we can start to work around that
but
uh that's that's some of the issue
uh and then on the cannibalising side
feminized seed what is feminized seed so
uh feminize obviously is is the female
uh in a diocese crop
generally speaking
it favors a little bit more the female
than male uh so probably
for most of us uh in the fields i guess
we'll see about 60 to 60 55 to 60 female
versus uh 40 to 45
um
male plants in there and a monash's
variety that
that ratio is essentially the same on a
long ancient plant so what i found in
the past there might be a slight yield
advantage to a monitious plant but uh on
a diesel side there's uh there doesn't
seem to be as much of a difference for
yield where it makes the difference is
on fiber quality because
those male plants die off
early and that fiber is is much
different than what the diocese or the
female plant is as it tends to live a
little bit longer and do a little more
work just kind of like what happens in
real life i think for most of us
but feminize of course on the cbd side
we just want to be growing we don't want
that energy spent on seed production we
want it spent on cannibal production
autoflower uh is the opposite of
phototropics so there are some
autoflower traits and some varieties
have autoflower traits where they will
be triggered more so on
days after planting as opposed to day
length and daylight
intensity so
that seems to be much more it came much
more from the marijuana genetics side of
things uh not a lot of the straight hemp
genetics have that autoflower trait in
them so
um that's uh you know it's a i wouldn't
say concern is of interest to the
breeders on how to trick the plant into
being able to be adapted in
different areas
around the world
so this kind of gives you an idea so
this is what's called the list of
approved cultivars in canada and a
variety has to be on this list for a
grower to grow it commercially uh in
canada and the requirements are
health canada is is part of the
regulatory board and so they basically
they test for thc essentially so
all the varieties that are on this board
have been tested numerous times and
they've been approved by health canada
that they will consistently or
predominantly stay below that point
three percent thc
the second part of that is the canadian
seed growers association so we have to
grow nothing but
certified pedigreed seeds sorry so
either at the very least the certified
level registered or breeder and that's
where the testing is done on the
pedigree level so a farmer when he grows
the crop he doesn't even have to test at
that point in time the testing for that
seed lot happens at the breeder stage of
that that raider seed is planted to to
uh to get registered seed the registry
served seed is uh also tested so again
as a registered or a pedigreed seed
grower that's my responsibility to test
that and send that away for analysis
and then when it goes into certified
seed and that certified seed is sold to
a farmer there's no longer a need for
testing and so it's something that you
know i'm also on the hia seeding grains
committee and and i and i i like this
for that reason alone there's sure
there's extra regulations there and and
uh but
you know for the farmer he he knows if
it's a pedigreed it's third-party
inspected there's stability new
uniformity um and and a difference
between so
we know um
he knows what's in that bag he knows
what the
percentage or the germination percentage
is as a processor if you're contracting
to grow that you know what you're
getting too so it's kind of a
i think a good
risk mitigator in the in the industry as
a whole
so when we're seeding
with hemp it's a small seed a little bit
uh about three quarters the size of
wheat perhaps
but we want to seed shallow um a half
inches maybe you know that's kind of
borderline half to an inch is probably
as deep as you would like to go
on the grain
side of things we target a 25 to 30
pound uh per acre seeding rate and of
course there's a difference in seed size
so we need to know what that uh for us
the thousand kernel weight or how you
know how many seeds are in a pound so we
need to make sure that we have that
calculation done
uh the higher seeding rates for fiber
again if we have a lower seeding rate
that plant has more time to spread out a
little bit more has more space
the
internodes get closer together it
branches more and when those internals
get closer together and it's not
reaching for the
sun or not um you know kind of uh
competing for the sunlight uh those
internodes kind of get closer together
what we want for fiber are those longer
intros we have a more high quality fiber
everywhere there's an internode uh
that's that's kind of a break in the
fiber essentially
um worn soils now this one you know
we're getting a lot of i wouldn't say
push back but there's a lot of
observations which are extremely true
that
when hemp is seeded
or sorry when hemp is harvested and
we've got some uh
seed left on the ground
that seed doesn't matter if you're in
manitoba where i am right now or or
anywhere if it has an opportunity to
germinate it will under a lot lower soil
conditions you will see that uh 50 and
55 is when the majority of seeds so one
of the biggest issues is mortality plant
mortality so
what we're seeing what i've seen in the
past is anywhere from third 20 to 70
seed mortality
predominantly because of cold wet soils
and so we want to make sure that we have
it you know give that seed every chance
that it can um because it's going to
have a a natural mortality in there you
know pythium other things root diseases
can be an issue but our target plant
stand in doing so
is about 10 to 12 plants per square foot
for the grain side of things and of
course higher uh
for fiber
equipment just about anything can be
used planters uh
double disc drills air seeders and for
us the the predominant
choice of equipment here on the prairies
is uh our air seeders uh and in that
case we just want to make sure that we
lower the fans speed because uh they
will get uh basically some
uh the the manifold where that seed
starts bouncing around turns into a
little bit of a coffee grind grinder and
that's when you open up that cap you'll
see it just mushes the seed it's a very
sensitive seed
this is just again a little bit of uh
to give you an idea if we look at the
maximum
1000 kernel weight uh so we've got you
know alyssa here which is a parkland
variety at 19. uh down to i believe
where can we see uh you know fenola is
one that is a very it's not even
on here no here we are fenola
14.6 uh grams per thousand kernels so a
much smaller seed
uh so that adjusts your seeding rate so
we can go anywhere from 18 pounds up to
24 or 25 pounds so that's the importance
of making sure that you do that
calculation
so this is just a picture of our farm
this is our our air seeder um we use
predominantly anhydrous ammonia as our
nitrogen source the seed is in the tank
our our phosphate fertilizer potassium
fertilizer is in there
if you can see my my mouse over this
manifold right here is where you know we
got to check that often so make sure
that we have the wind
lowered more so than wheat or even
canola
because as it comes off this primary
distribution point here into these hoses
this is where the damage is done so if
that's not turned down we have a heck of
a mess there and the potential for
uh clogging of the of the air hose so a
little bit on fertility we we did a
fertility uh a nutrient uptake study
some time ago uh i think it was about
2004 or five again uh with one of our
taller varieties at that point uh so you
can see in comparison to canola is what
we did because that was really our other
cash crop so when we're talking about
total plant nutrient uptake
as we know kilograms per hectare can be
relatively
uh switched over to pounds per acre uh i
think it's less
10 something like that
not not much of additions but you can
you know relatively speaking you can
compare so as far as nitrogen goes we
found that hemp was using up to 200
pounds of nitrogen in the in the growth
cycle of which we've got 40 pounds of
nitrogen that was captured in the grain
itself so if you're taking that grain to
a processor off the field you know that
on an average yield of say 2000 pounds
or sorry a thousand pounds or 1500
pounds of grain uh you're taking about
40 pounds per uh acre of nitrogen off
with an uptake of about six and a half
you know canola we're taking more off so
we've got to replace more uh nitrogen
after the fact so a lot of this nitrogen
is tied up in the stock which will leach
back into the ground if we can make sure
that we have some sort of a reading
process or or or an opportunity for that
straw to take on some moisture
um
phosphate here 47 pounds very similar to
canola
and in the grain we're taking 19. the
big one here too is potassium so if we
are into the fiber industry taking off
the crop green uh not allowing reading
to happen you know we could we we need
to keep a good eye on those potassium
levels because uh the the
the total plant uptake of course is
quite high we're not taking much off in
the grain it's again tied up mostly uh
in that stock um so it can it can be
leached back in but
you do need to be aware of that and of
course it needs that much potassium for
you know for straw strength which makes
sense it's a tall crop once again
uh some of the disease issues um you
know sclerotinia seems to be about one
of the the biggest ones you can see the
sclerosis body here within the stock
uh that's going to drop down and create
those apothecia that uh and and there's
so many hosts for scleritania including
soybeans breast canola
so that's another one that we have to
make sure to keep an eye on
to date we haven't seen you know i
haven't seen an absolute catastrophe on
this but there's a certain percentage
for sure
uh the other one in botrytis or
white mold we see this often also it's
kind of the same thing it's for us on
the prairies again i think if we move uh
sort of then northeast or eastern more
humid areas in the u.s this can become
more of an issue so
again there's some varieties that can
handle or have a bit more of a
resistance to to these varieties to
these diseases but on the grain side of
things these are some of the ones that
are causing an issue in canada i guess
predominantly
uh insects
we've got a
european corn borer on the left here we
don't have a lot of corn where i'm at
yet but we did happen to find uh one of
these in the stock uh in the in the
actually in the stem uh starting to
cause issues so that one is of concern
the middle here is a bertha army worm
which uh basically the foliage feeders
like the grasshopper on the right here i
mean there's so much biomass there they
just seem to eat a bunch of it and then
hop away unless we have a very extensive
extensive um
infestation and uh like japanese beetle
i think is is a huge one in the u.s too
that i've seen uh hemp get uh basically
stripped because of that so
i think for the most part the seed heads
are protected again from the trichomes
you know we see a lot of aphids in the
greenhouse production is different uh
when we're outside uh not quite uh not
quite the same
frost uh
appear in canada you know every second
day we can get a frost and in fact in
one summer we had a frost every month
but uh here was a seating date study
that i was trialing uh so i had
different uh
different uh seating dates with with
crop at different plant stages so we
went right from the beginning of may
seeded right up to the first week of
july actually so we got this frost uh
may 30th minus 4.7 so that's just just
below freezing but you know hard enough
for a killing frost you can see the
smaller seedlings here the yellowing uh
some keroses there just from stress
not as much of an effect on the larger
ones the earlier seeded so if they can
get established
again we're okay but it's just getting
them out of the ground uh in comparison
here's the soybean that was uh decimated
and this is flax that had to be reseeded
so it seems to be able to handle frost
on on both sides of both spring and fall
here's a picture of a hail outfield was
one of our
customers
believe it or not he left this and this
isn't the field of his on the right
right-hand side but this is essentially
what happens this was a later uh event
where there was wind or this could have
been wind but you see how we call this
goosenecking and essentially you know as
hard as it is or as hard as it seems to
be to get the plant established um it's
it's a resilient bugger too it just
wants to grow all the time and you can
see here starts reaching for the sun
again uh trying to compete and we'll do
anything it can to to survive so the
field on the left this is what there was
there was basically sticks and he ended
up
with about 60 of the yield potential of
that he left it this
that hail storm happened in uh the
middle of july there was nothing else
that he could do so
just to give you an idea if all you know
if if you get something like that and uh
just just wait a couple days see if
you've got anything once again growing
up out of those internals
and this is what i was mentioning
earlier you can kind of see in the top
left where the bracket material is
slowly drying down and the seed is being
exposed particularly the one where if
you can see my mouse is just sitting
there uh you know if a bird happens to
be coming by they see that that's uh
that's pretty uh juicy for them so
um but this is kind of the same time
that we want to start looking at harvest
so timing of harvest is a tough one to
tell because
what we want to do to limit the amount
of wrapping and i'll show you pictures
of what wrapping will look like uh we
try to harvest the crop when this when
the grain moisture is in that 10 to 20
percent moisture range uh you want to
slow everything down uh your cylinder
speed your rotor speed uh open things up
as far as your concave
because you can crack the seat and that
will affect not only the germination if
it's a seed crop but it will also uh
create some uh oxidation within the city
and it's uh it's an issue with oil
quality and actually if you ever have
open up a bag of hemp hearts and you see
browns in there that's because it was
the seed was cracked and it's oxidized
um so you need to dry it down below 10
for safe storage
um there are um
a couple different moisture meters that
you can have that actually do have hemp
as far as being able to determine what
that moisture is so very important to
have that
in there so this is uh this is the
combine that i use now um i'll show you
i don't have my other combine but i was
used to most of my previous experience
was in a small plot combine and i used
an old old hagy because it uh it was
easy enough to just have a summer
student in the back if it ever got
plugged now this one a different story
we
you know a macdon header we like uh the
the fingers here flip up uh it's got
nice space on the draper so the
objective is to feed the hemp as
straight as possible to have it go
through the combine once or one and a
half turns around the rotor and then out
the back and so that's kind of the
objective there basically um there is of
course no hemp so i just superimposed
hemp over top of this body setting but
these are my settings in the combine so
my cylinder or sorry rotor speed is at
470.
my concave clearance is at 26
millimeters my wind is about 870 rpm
my uh chaffer's at set at 16 and my
sieve is set at six so these settings
are maybe a little bit larger than wheat
we've got a good flow of air because
we've got so much chaff material but
slow it down and open things up a little
bit because it does show or harvest
quite easily
this is some of the wrapping issues that
i mentioned this is just a
spline on the on the driveshaft of the
front of john deere
and that's just from going over the
headlands where you've harvested if
there's a place for it to to pick up and
wrap it will
this is the cleaning fan of that
also starting to wrap in there so you do
have to kind of get out there and make
sure that you don't have these problems
and and
forward thinking uh basically uh
there's a show that used to be called
red green and his favorite tool was his
duct tape
it makes uh it makes a
it makes a genius out of most of us so
we just took some pvc pipe here put some
duct tape around it hemp didn't have a
chance this is that same shaft didn't
have a chance to wrap on there
this is in the back of the combine the
back meter
this is an issue too so it starts to
wrap on the on the shaft there and this
is where you start to get smoke from the
inside of the combine which really makes
a person kind of sit up and take notice
uh but the same thing we just used some
baler belting hair bolted that onto that
beater
and rubbing the side of the wall kind of
cleared that issue so there's as as
farmers they you know they figure this
stuff out and and we're happy to sort of
pass on that knowledge uh for grain
production uh this is a necessity to
always have a fire extinguisher even if
you're doing plots um it's not a matter
of if you'll smell smoke it's when
for sure it's just the nature of working
with this crop
this is the
uh labronics what is it 919 i guess it
is that will test for you can go to the
canadian cranes grains commission there
is a chart there for him
um storage and handling i'm not sure how
i'm doing time here
we want to make sure that we uh have as
little contamination as possible
especially for grain production uh so
cleaning your your harvest and handling
equipment clean out the bins
there's really no kill stop within the
process of hemp you take the hemp from
the farmer's bin goes to a seed cleaner
from the seed cleaner it goes to the
processor processor will either de-haul
or or or cold press the oil
so there's an opportunity for a lot of
micro talk mycotoxins to form so in
canada here because of the canola
industry this is very
prominent on our in our vineyards uh
dryers uh these are just hop whoops
sorry hop of our hopper bottom bins with
aeration uh to make sure that
as soon as we get uh you know even even
we don't even feel semis anymore we just
use tandems uh get that get that product
on air as quick as possible because if
you're at 12 percent moisture
you know that uh
those those plate counts of of uh
disease not mycotoxins start to rise and
that food quality can be uh
in jeopardy
so a dryer can work but again low and
slow is the idea there uh you want to
make sure that you don't post the hemp
that if it's toasted ham if it does done
by the
processor so the take home message dry
low and slow
what what are the issues bacterial mold
growth time temperature and moisture uh
time is the only one that we can really
have an effect on so we need to get that
uh again that product on air as quick as
possible
so i don't think uh you know i'll just
kind of briefly go through so kind of
kind of in my production in canada
there's both outdoor and indoor uh these
are again a much different looking plant
uh hemp plant than the grain production
it's much more i call them more of a
christmas tree look and uh whereas i
think what we're trying to do in the
grain side of things is make it more
like a palm tree where you know we've
got two foot of seed head and maybe a
foot of stock is the ideal amount of
hemp that we want and stuff so
uh again we're trying to harvest these
little trichomes uh is the objective
there uh it's much more like i said as a
uh like a christmas tree type operation
which i'm sure most of you have seen
this
again and it's only been since 2017 when
canada was able to start to actually
play with the leaf material or the
flower material until then we could only
take the seed and the stock off the
field
all of that had to stay on so
we are now just getting into more of
these genetics
just an example here this is a variety
of grain variety on the left this is a
cbd variety right down the middle it's a
replicated trial that was i did on my
own farm you know a couple couple weeks
later you can see the the the canopy
closes in very rapidly um so
there's not uh you know you have to make
sure that you've got a weed control plan
uh with that low planting rate as
opposed to the grain which is seated at
25 pounds per acre this is probably
seated at
well it's it's probably 2500 plants per
acre
so quite a difference
so autoflower varieties i think uh are
important part of it um seed
certification again i i i'm a strong
proponent of seed certification uh to
know what you're getting um
and this is this is just a friend of
mine that had some cbd production and
sent the picture i thought it looked
kind of cool
this is his uh unit as far as harvesting
for flower materials so again this is an
outdoor grow uh same kind of combine
that i have just a newer one
uh basically he sets his system so that
he closes the sieve and chaffer down the
flower material goes into the back a
little bit of grain goes into the tank
that flower material in the back is then
immediately frozen i think in his case
and then extracted for cbd
this is uh
from formation ag a company out of
colorado that i i've been to enough
trade shows with that we share videos
back and forth uh kind of give you an
idea what that looks like this is their
unit again uh so this is again outdoor
production which is the
predominant one in in canada there are a
few greenhouses but just because of our
cold winters it's uh you know the
production predominantly is is outside
uh so with that
um
[Music]
harvesting fiber i mean there's there's
a ton of ways we're getting to know a
little bit about this i guess the only
thing that i'll say about fiber this is
some of the fiber trials we were doing
uh back in the day
uh when i was a younger man thinner man
uh
reading process this is the one that i
think that a lot of work needs to be
done you know we the writing process is
almost like you know in china they've
got a wet wet wet rat
we don't have enough experience here we
don't know what environment is really
going to do we don't have even enough
processing to tell us this is what they
want most of the processing is for herd
which you know the writing effect has a
process has an effect but this was
predominantly for producing
high quality
textile fiber which is you know which is
the highest value for for hemp fiber
so with that i think the you know the
moon is bright it's a picture of my uh
call mine this year i thought it was
kind of cool uh then i had a beautiful
sunset one day too so with that i just
want one more announcement and before i
go so uh hgi uh um is a company that i
currently work for as of two weeks ago
uh we are proud to announce that we are
have merged with a company called
tritium t3h which is in the bottom right
here tritium is the one that i mentioned
had a lot of the genetics on the cbd
varieties
we just felt it was a good fit industry
is still kind of small our new company
will be called bird seed solutions i've
been
nominated i guess or or hired on as a
general manager
my twitter account's the same this is my
new address um
both tony
all the people have both my hemp
genetics and this this address so more
than happy to
answer as many questions i can i know i
kind of maybe win a little bit over time
but with that i'll i'll turn it back
over to uh
to our crew here so thank you very much
uh thank you
jeff that was incredible something tells
me you probably could have gone for
three more hours with
a lot of high depth
information that was really fun and
fascinating uh and we
greatly appreciate your time
um i know tony has been working on some
of the questions here let's let's put uh
jeff through the ringer and see how many
he can answer
so um
first question we have a lot of
questions here so i'll try to get
through as many as possible before uh
the 3 pm mark um
so babu
from lincoln university asks
can you please suggest a plot combine
for us to harvest the grains the one we
used this year got fire after the fiber
stuck inside sp20
yeah um
the new the new winter tiger ones i
forget the name their eclipse maybe i
think they're able to handle
uh hemp now what i was using again was
uh an old heggy uh 125b
and that
you know if you can find one of those
with an adjustable sieve that will work
um
zern makes one that i think you know
zern kind of came off of uh you know
when heggy was bought by winter steiger
half went to winner steiner half point
discern so those are the two that i know
but
it's the the beater you got to watch
right under your butt there uh
and uh that's that's generally where
you'll get some rapping
lloyd wilson asks can you please give us
a percentage of hemp grown outside
versus indoor growing i assume he means
in canada
well for canada yeah we're you know as
far as hemp acres
um
yeah i would say
you know 99 is outdoor uh with a one
percent uh as far as the revenue uh
that's a different story i guess because
of the high cannabinoid revenue but i
it's still
you know particularly there's there's
some indoor operations in d.c
a couple in ontario uh though the
western prairies um uh are predominantly
all outside um outdoors so yeah
well in the 90s for sure
iris asks can seed serve for multiple
use
example a seed that serves as cbd be
used for grain fiber
the short answer is yes the long answer
is no what we're finding particularly
because we are exporting product into
the eu now so thc is a concern as is now
becoming cbd so there are some
tri-purpose crops where we've got um a a
good grain yield or an average grain
yield lots of fiber but still some high
cannabinoid in that flour
and high i mean four to six percent what
we're finding is some of that cbd is
being transferred onto the seed goes
into the food product and and the eu
will start testing for that in a not too
distant future so it is a concern so
uh
that's what i mean yes it can it is kind
of the same seed there might be some
differences within oil content or amino
acid profile but
yeah the seed is basically the same
laura asks any research available on
degradation of cannabinoids during
storage
in biomass
that's coming we worked uh with the
prairie
machinery institute in canada this is
also a chta project uh on basically on
both things on so now we know exactly
how many cfus we need to make sure that
we can maintain that quality in hand and
and their second part of that project is
how quickly we need to dry down um
uh basically hemp
flour for cannabinoid production now i
the degradation i think comes into more
play when in regards to the over
handling of it it's it's it's the same
thing so you're working with a wet
material probably 30 40 moisture at
least and so mold is going to be an
issue so you got to make sure that you
saw it quickly went through that one
round baler there it's called an oracle
baler so some people have put that
biomass at a higher moisture wrapped it
with plastic once the oxygen was used up
in that so you do have some and styling
happen once the oxygen oxygen's used up
they were still able to
have the majority of that product still
be good so that's that's another
important one i think there's more
research that needs to be done
okay
dr ryan robinson asks are there dry
disinfection methods that have been
considered i have been aware of
non-thermal plasma treatments of seeds
to prevent mold and bacterial growth
there's some that we use
not infrared light
uh
basically
uh
removing the oxygen etc uh i can't
remember just the name escapes me right
now
there's
there's things that that are there but
most of them are are kind of a wet
solution uh and that does tend to leave
a taste on him so
uh there's a few
kill stops that are coming along the
biggest one is that we just can't use
heat because that all of a sudden starts
to
play with the nutritional value of the
of the seed and that's one of our major
selling features is that high protein
very good
you know omega-3 omega six omega nine
portfolios
okay so uh next question
kind of a two-part question
uh cindy asks
uh your slide said no clone purchases at
this time
is it illegal to sell hemp plants in
canada
and bill asks you said nope clones
approved at ayasko we certified the
first cbd clone unicorn could our
certified clone be approved in canada
yeah we're working on it in canada so
that's exactly what we need is to bridge
that data so that was the thing so i
think you know
utilizing the likes of the potato
industry with a tuber uh it's just you
know there has to be a certification
there so
it's just it was not in canada yet
doesn't mean that you couldn't have your
own greenhouse start the plants there
and transplant but the sale of clones
although happened and happens uh is
you know under the regulations not not
real i guess
okay
uh that's great
so daniel lopez uh
says our farm is in a tropical location
how will that impact the plant cycles
that's a very good question and i mean
you know obviously there's genetics from
there they're likely more backgrounded
in in marijuana i'm i'm guessing um but
on a photoperiod plant that's the thing
i i predict if we sent if we sent our
variety crs1 to you it would grow
probably two to three inches start
flowering and that that would be it uh
it just
there just is not that day length
difference that it can um
adapt to
so autoflower would be an option and uh
and like i said uh there's there's
thousands and thousands of genetics or
or this is this is a plant that's uh
uh the most
the most uniform thing about hemp is
that it's non-uniform like it's it's
it's extremely difficult to you know to
certify a crop and the pollen flow is so
prolific um
you know it's just it's just uh it's a
challenge to keep varieties pure
so
uh
from my knowledge like at least for our
varieties that's the impact would have
would be
basically just a plant that tall
um lamar asks what us registry exists or
is being developed for pre-approved
green and or fiber varieties
um i mean there's this is the tricky
part about the us because it
you know let's say that each of your
states seems to be a country in its own
and so there's different you know
colorado has a certification but that's
just for colorado no it's not just for
colorado they can put the colorado
certification on there and it almost
sounds like the colorado seed growers
association is all the same as the
canadian sea growers association but
that all they do there is look at the
thc content
where the aos certification is is third
party inspected so that the breeder has
to say okay this variety has to look
distinctly different from this variety
with these these traits or aspects so
that's the uniformity part of it so a
certain percentage can can fall outside
of that so if you had a dioecious crop
predominantly and you had a uh
hermaphrodite in there that's where you
start to get that cross-pollination
you're only allowed so much of that so
so aos oecd are are the two that are
sort of world
recognized i guess and the ios is really
the north american one
um so
there are some of the hemp companies in
u.s are going down that same route even
on the cbd side uh arcadia bioscience um
um
jeremy klecke up in oregon he they also
go uh with aosp certification
it's not mandatory but
i yeah i guess i i think it's a good
thing
awesome uh babu has another question um
have you noticed differences in herd
filling in the fiber hemp stock any
suggestion we found some varieties with
hollow insides
yeah
that's a lot of that's varietal could be
moisture also uh again uh it's a great
re research project
um seeding rate seeding density i guess
seeding uh seating date and bridle i
would say those are the three things
that you want to take a look there um
but you're absolutely right i think
seating density like
to to to get the most amount of fiber
off an acre of
crop you you want your stock to be
pencil thin like this is again the
basque fiber gives you the highest
quality basque fiber i'm not necessarily
sure on herd i think you can probably
reduce that to grow more herd within
that but there's got to be a point in
there where there's a trade-off right so
again that's a it's another great um
herd was was really just a byproduct you
know it was uh what the heck are we
gonna do with the hurt once we got all
this fast fiber now it's the exact
opposite to a degree
where herd has a pretty good value right
now for bedding and everything else in
ham crete where the basque fiber we
don't just don't have the processing in
north america
to scale uh to make that uh and then
anytime we're shipping bales it's always
an issue right
awesome thank you for that
uh jarius asks
does the thc level fluctuate throughout
the growing process of hemp and if so
how do you maintain the 0.3 thc level
so there is a
technical manual that the health canada
puts out for when you are supposed to
test for thc
uh in these crops so basically in a
nutshell it's when 50 of the seeds
so obviously a grain crop or a fiber
crop when 50 of the seeds resist
compression is the time that they
suggest that you take so i know the
difference in the us where you
continually take thc testing until you
get to a point where you know
that 20 days later you have to harvest
and you know that if i can wait until
here then i still fall within regulation
or canada it's not so it's it's grown uh
there's a certain um physiological time
when you have to test on a feminized
plant and also on a grain plant so yes
it will fluctuate i've seen it fluctuate
after a yield i mean
again uh that the uh the non-uniformity
part of the hetero heterozygous aspect
of him you can test one hemoplast and it
it changes
within the structure of the plant too so
the top
the top whatever top two or three inches
has a higher uh
cbd or cantilevering content than the
bottom leaves like the we call there's
the sugar leaves and the families um so
there's differences not only
uh
there's just differences
varietal
environmental uh
fertility if it's under stress it seems
to me i know larry
will probably argue with you maybe a lot
of it is genetic and it doesn't change
but um that's that's what you don't have
to talk to over a beer sometimes
so the
one of the leading researchers on this
question is
sitting in the zoom call i don't know if
george wants to chime in or not but uh
he wrote an awesome paper about this
question
it's probably too hard to summarize in
five minutes
yeah i mean my study was mostly focused
on high cbd varieties um and obviously
it's it's very variety specific
um
so there's definitely a genetic
component and then there's an
environmental component to to total
cannabinoid content um and every variety
is different so you have to be familiar
with what you're growing just as jeff
said
thanks thanks george i've been following
your work there for sure
we kind of met a couple years ago there
so yeah perfect thanks
awesome we have one final question i
believe this is ernie from alabama a m
he says since you do not test for thc at
farm production can we rely on your
genetics for the 0.03 level
uh that is enforced at farm production
in the us
i can confidently say that for three of
our varieties for sure um um our save
variety crs one which is the ones that
do better in the us anyway i i mean
we've tested them for
just about 20 years they were they were
actually
taken off the list to even have to test
and then health canada changed it again
so it's just they are so stable they're
just so low in thc they they just do not
go over uh unless you do something
completely some sort of a
you know spray or you know there are are
tricks or things that
other growers use to enhance thc and cbd
if it's grown in a commercial
you would not have to worry you know
awesome
thank you um
i guess we do have time for one more
question this might be
uh more towards for you zack um cindy
cooper asks is anybody working to get
hemp designated as a usda specialty crop
that will open access to millions of
research dollars
i do not know the answer to that
question honestly i i think it's a
very valid question um i'm a little bit
upstream
of that right now um
george do you know
i i have not heard of anybody doing that
but
i wouldn't be surprised if somebody is
working on it
awesome
um well i believe that is
we're at time um i'm sorry if i didn't
get to your question but um if i did not
get to your question please reach out to
jeff with the email he provided
um
i want to say uh join us again in two
weeks
where we'll have dr bruce bugbee of utah
state university talking about indoor
cultivation
so i really look forward to that talk
and thank you all for joining this talk
yeah thank you so much this is yeah just
looking at the participants that's been
one of the highest participant level
that i've spoke to in some time
appreciate it if anybody happens to be
going to world egg expo in california
and tulare we're we're going to have a
booth there so drop in and say hi
it's one of my first trips after this
big kobe lockdown
so yeah looking forward to stretching
the legs so thank you very much for the
opportunity to tony zach and george uh
really appreciate it and again anything
else we can do to collaborate with any
of the other research institutes i'm i'm
i'm all for it um that's i said as i
said that's my bread and butter so i i
think it's a huge value for the industry
awesome
you're getting a lot of thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu